hallo leute ist es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einem neuen wie
schmeckt oder anderen koch video und
heute bin ich nicht alleine hier denn
ich habe den großartigen einzigartigen
fabian siegismund
nicht wahlberg gut okay ich bin fit aber
ich wäre so gerne kratos karte oder wer
ist denn kratos das ist natürlich der
golfer und ich mache gerade eine video
reihe wo ich versuche wie er zu werden
und dabei wichtige dankeschön haben wir
wollen gibt es ja nein wir machen heute
knäckebrot ok mit kräuterbutter ok konto
warum macht mit knäckebrot du hattest ja
jetzt schon dein look bekommen
wir haben es schon sport und jetzt kommt
es auf die inneren werte an und dafür
ist fleisch schon richtig gut ja keine
frage aber die wirklichen kraft bringer
sind samen und kräuter machen dich von
ihnen
nach sehr gut sehr gut haben wir noch
mal über den start zu gehen start
ich mag das bei mir dann in den westen
oft texten zu
im neuesten teil der gedok im neuesten
teil der gedo im neuesten teil der god
of war reihe schlüpft ihr wieder in die
haut des kriegers kratos und kämpft euch
in die og manier durch die spielwelt
viele jahre nach seiner rache an den
göttern hat er sich im norden abgesetzt
und einen sohn bekommen mit dem er dort
lebt das spiel sieht also nicht nur
atemberaubend aus sondern wird eine
packende story über die suche nach einer
hoffnungsvollen zukunft bieten
und bei meiner recherche zu
skandinavischen rezepten bin ich auf
knäckebrot gestoßen ja knäckebrot durch
seine nährstoffe haltbarkeit und größe
ist wie gemacht für den kampf es ist
also der perfekte snack für jeden
krieger oder die die es noch werden
wollen
[Musik]
es ist die sogenannte speise kley und
wir brauchen 80 gramm weise bleibt 80
kann ja direkt aus war hand aber so
leicht ist das 120 km h fahren
haferflocken die kenne ich und jetzt
machen wir natürlich hasse dich anfassen
nah gut weil ich gerade das bringt kann
ich ihn anfassen da probleme damit
unbehandeltes holz du bist ja was ist
denn das für ein natürlich noch die
guten kerne samen alles was das ding so
richtig gut macht wenn du wüsstest was
ich ständig bezogen die ersten samen wir
haben das sind leinsamen wollen
zweifel sind wir gut wie kann man auch
wenn wir den ganz großen showdown gut
alles ja kommen die zionisten samen sie
samen sammeln was können sie samen gut
für dein und mir rennen
für deine liebe und für die knochen und
zähne ellbogenstoß sonnenblumen kam
die sind nämlich auch fossile knochen
und fleisch sagt die haselnüsse reinhold
hasen reinpacken und jetzt haben wir
noch ein sogar es supergut der
kürbiskerne sind auf der liste
kürbiskerne ich hab ich diesen test
lernen würde 80 prozent ungesättigte
fettsäuren vitamin c betakarotin
magnesium eisen thing und wählen 30
jetzt machen wir sehen also sollte ich
zum bisher nicht irgendwo wie führen so
ein bisschen jetzt haben alle trockenen
zutaten
jetzt kommen wir zu dem festlichen
zutaten hat neben lady 6 die perfekte
kombination von omega 3 und omega 6
fettsäuren also drei zu irgendwas
[Musik]
und jetzt noch die quelle wird leben
hier
ich bin schockiert meinem training so
was mal wird da jetzt ist köchin julia
ja am anfang ist es schon immer so ein
bisschen
ich habe ehrlich gedacht dass besagte
dass es besser wird
weil es so wie can't find ich mit
knäckebrot auswirkungen sagen wird
einfach mal dass es genauso aus
ja und jetzt kommt das auch jetzt noch
max ja ich mag jetzt einfach dadurch
dass da so machen erstmal so die hälfte
damit wir kommentieren können ob das
überhaupt ja sieht aber auch schon dass
hier heute hat können oder so sondern
kann ist wie gilt draus machen so das
muss jetzt für erst mal 15 minuten bei
160 grad in den ofen
danach müssen das nämlich so
zurechtschneiden und dann noch mal 45
minuten meiner wenn jetzt schlau gewesen
wären hätte mir natürlich der besitz
oder werden es live gestreamt wer hat
das wäre natürlich auch kannst du das
bitte eingeladen weil du magst kein holz
ich mag eine schnecke brot das jetzt
angeschnitten und muss noch weitere 45
minuten im ofen sein
in der zeit wolle man es natürlich nicht
langweilen sondern machen selber mutter
und zwar kräuterbutter also heute ganz
viele erste male erst wenn ich jetzt
sheikh said tut das nass als kind update
wie und dem ohne witz dass die sahne
stellt man so lange draußen kennst das
nämlich wenn man schlag seine macht dass
man halt aufpassen los sein
man muss bei schlagsahne ich mich
aufpassen weil irgendwann kommt dieser
punkt damit so klebrig puttrich aber
wenn du diesen punkten überschreiten so
ein bayer macht bis zum ende
30 45 minuten ungefähr bis zu fußball
wir uns auf deine hin muskelkraft
wir nehmen jetzt mal 3 becker ich denke
mal das wird
das habe ich tatsächlich noch nie
gesehen dass jemand sich mutter
schüttelt ich glaube zwei reichen
erstmal aus
du weißt dass das jetzt gleichauf geht
und alles voller panischer angst davor
aber ich denke die sahne und auch drei
stunden dann wird auch niemals gute
auswahl
[Musik]
wie können die maschine benutzen damals
dass du bist du hast du fabian sind
nicht fertig klingt klingt fast so
klingt wie butter da die mutter hat mir
da jetzt unten noch was ist darunter und
buttermilch ja ach das wird jetzt dann
also ab gesiebt ich habe gedacht das
kann man doch einfach irgendwo verlags
[Musik]
vielleicht aber die butter ist auch
schon um aufnahme ist dh oder halt das
bedingungen oben oder fällungen wir das
jetzt nach naja war das echt lecker aus
ja und ich glaube an mainz das ist jetzt
gut du bist hat das jetzt eigentlich
meinen job aber aber personal führen das
ist wie ich meine überlegung sei hier
aus möglich heraus möglich ist jetzt
kommen die kräuter kunden das ist das
los war im juni an
ohne kraut künstlers mit lauf ja gut
hensley kräuter ich kenne meine kräutern
so gut dann msn axt faktisch
m2m wird man sagen wenn ihm ein normales
besser so dass jetzt da rein
nachdem ihr ja also die krise schön
immer die petersilie die entgiftet
nämlich deinen körper und hilft bei
sodbrennen das leistungsvermögen und in
dein herz sein gestärkt und besser im
kopf und bald ja klar
dann bleibst du dir einfach mit
petersilie 3 und schon du bist sehr
beschneidet ich danke schön wenn es eine
klinge hat mag ich ist jeder braucht
einen kater carlo schmid blau nicht
glaubhaft wie vitamin a und c verstehe
und hilft bei entzündungen und reinigt
das blut da machst du jetzt das so
können wir das nur sagen jetzt 100 das
zipfeln wie thymian den zitiert dass ich
versuche alles zu kriegen
ich glaube ich einfach angelegt dass
auch heute noch manchmal nicht rausgehen
weil fleckenstein
was hast du ein stein mit ja
so viele monate habe ich schon diesen
eco salz steigern wusste nicht was ich
denken kann man da was wir haben jetzt
kräuterbutter gemacht es war ganz
einfach das war wirklich einfach
also nicht nur jetzt wenn ihr gerade zu
besuch gehabt auch die grillparty es
gibt mal mit einer 68 in kräuterbutter
an er freundlich noch nicht sagen ach so
kräuter reingemacht und sagst du nein
selber geschüttelt und dann macht es
doch die bewegung dazu nein er hier
machst du nicht die halbe nacht hatte
ich heute hier haben wir jetzt unsere
selbstgemachten brote und ich bin etwas
wunderschön oder pleitegehen zu stellen
hatte er fahre ich schon gesagt wow ja
ok oh wie schön wie schön angerichtet
sie das hat ich warte noch auf dich
gehört aber ich spreche hier schon
einige jahre post post die kräuterbutter
das total lecker kauf von pizza auch ich
glaube das ist der typische merkmale ist
mit starkem oder das bild auch wenn es
ein bisschen länger als 60 minuten im
ofen haben damit so richtig knusprig
aber das ist der sommer wird ein win-win
frische foto was ist das etwa die
werbung axt die werbung absatz gesagt
werbung ist es gibt noch einen windspiel
mainka was gibt es denn zu gewinnen
zum start von border vor am zwanzigsten
april bis dahin könnt ihr eine ps4
prokop war limited edition gewohnt mich
nur das sondern auch fünf god of war
spiele also schaut euch den link unten
in der infobox an
denn da kommt hier zum gewinnspiel wir
müssen macht eine frage beantworten und
zwar wie heißt grad auch so gut aus na
ja klar was eigentlich du den namen
ausgesucht oder deine frau er ist
von den göttern ein gesagt worden radios
und wer jetzt nicht genug von kratos
habt also diesen wunderschönen
muskulösen gott dann schaut jetzt auf
den kanälen von der mutter marie und
johannes lukas verwunderlicher marie
habt mir dieses krasse make up gemacht
ich hab mich so erschrocken als ich dann
wird es erst mal gesehen habe da
wirklich so schön geworden
schön also doch schön da kann man schon
mal schön sagen schön
apropos schule wissen wollt wie das
kostüm entstanden ist das gibt es zum
beispiel in meinem konto zu werden dann
schaut abhilfe auch da vorbei und dann
würden wir jetzt mal sagen
gehen wir mal die kritik kommt von einem
greenscreen effekt so richtig schlecht
ein
[Musik]